thank you
[Music]
um so there is a delivery service that
um quote abandoned a sofa that was stuck
on a staircase I mean they just left it
they just couldn't wedge it up
it's just stuck on the staircase aren't
they supposed to bring it back down and
like hey we can't deliver you guys these
guys were basically just like hey shrug
of the Year dude that doesn't happen to
like like this happened to our house we
got we got some new washing machines
and the guys from Home Depot were
supposed to come and install it and the
guy and I wasn't there and Tiff was the
one having having to deal with it
because I was here
and the guys are like oh yeah man like
we can't even get this in here and she's
like you guys can't get this water
machine through this doorway she was
like ah yeah I don't think we can and I
think your landlord didn't buy stackable
washing machine units so this is not
gonna even fit
and then like yeah so we just have to
leave it outside and it was like that
week dude it was that week where La was
raining started raining like crazy so we
have this washing machine covered in
plastic just out in the rain and every
day we're like [__] is this gonna be
ruined oh my God you didn't call home
people like [__] I pay for the
install why don't you call why don't you
call Steve Green because I [__] did
this [__] myself see that's what I
should have done I should have called
you go as smoothly as you claim that's
not true because um yeah we had a little
bit of leak but I did install it a
washing machine yeah washing washer and
dryer mode you're a [__] man bro and
I did with the furniture dolls with a
little bit of a leak a little bit of a
leak we have a little bit of a leak but
you just gotta plug it in the correct
holes
all right you do it next time also
Anthony probably knows a lot about you
are you good with washer and dryers and
[__] Anthony Pockets like this in front
of a washer dryer no you are they
weren't regular washer and drives I can
handle washer dryer but those are like
dry cleaning machines and presses and
stuff
Echelon of you know talent and skills
yeah you know it ain't exactly just this
it's nice we had a leak a massive leak
because it came from the uh washing
machine because it was broken like it
just kept going when you when it's not
supposed to like keep feeling possessed
yeah and that's why I I just laugh
because it's like recently I had to buy
a new one put it together so I was like
oh [__] that's how it works dude the
best thing because like I was installing
our washer dryer right and then Nikki
like comes up and she's like why are you
doing this she's like you she's like you
know that that could leak and I'm not
kidding it was like a [__] sitcom at
the exact same time it's always when
they say it I pull the nozzle out and
then I'm like oh [__] it's like [__]
that that hose things is going like this
all over the inside of the [__] thing
yeah and it was like it was like a
quarter inch of water all over the floor
yeah yeah yeah but why was it on
well because I didn't know to turn it
off
I'ma show this [__] [__] so you
didn't turn off the water yeah I was
like she thinks I'm not a [__] enemy
I want to show this [__] [__] and
the whole time I am talking to myself
like I'm [__] oh I'm gonna get this
[__] and then she comes there's audio
what are you doing you're [__] gonna
[__] it all and then it'll be everywhere
it was crazy it was like clockwork but
when you put it together didn't you feel
like yo I'm a [__] mate I was it was
a Triumph yeah Peter Travis called it a
Triumph
you know what I mean
it was a big moment in my life when I so
like I've lived a lot in different
places right I've never [__] touched
any other things because as soon as
something breaks I'm like that's the
[__] owner's fault yeah yeah and I
call him I'm like hey this is done and
then someone would come and fix it you
ever done that but then like your own
phone rings and you're like oh [__] we
did I am the owner
that's what happened no now now I have
to do everything yep but it's fun yeah I
didn't realize how [__] fun all this
[__] was it's so fun but this is more
fun okay let's go I just left that [__]
[__] they don't give up they just
literally left it I want one of those
you don't want this one I'll take it
that's massive hey if they want me to
get it out of the way why the [__] would
they just and they just bounce and yeah
they biz ounced right wait how did they
get it in there oh no check this out
they left it like this oh you see all
the cracks [__] look at the walls dude
they [__] it all up yeah they were
like did they move it in
we pinballed it up the stairs like
idiots and they just left it there holy
[__] oh my God look at that [__] dude
looks like a topographical map Home
Depot did this no no no these are this
is specters this is some Contracting
spaces but look that's a new place look
at the carpet that's brand new brand new
crown molding no that actually looks
like a JK office what though it does
this is 1.5 million dollars they had
just finished it too now they gotta redo
a bunch of [__] dude that massive hole I
know dude that's insane drywall must
have been weak I just like that you get
that massive hole and you keep cutting
it up we almost got it
more quenching in the wall dude there's
a tape measure that could have solved
all this oh [__] damn that sucks so
that's what they're saying the movers
are like it's your responsibility to
know if the dimensions are right for us
to get it up those angles like that's on
why do they try
I mean because they're kind of Legends
dude I would have looked at it and been
like this ain't gonna fit bro so he so
the the homeowner says that the The Sofa
Company ignored his warnings that the
staircase was narrow and then they just
basically said [__] it and and the sofa
was worth over 2 000 pounds which is
like basically like 17 000 in American
money oh oh it's you pay monies yeah UK
money I'm not very good in the
conversions
I'm not good at the conversions that's
my approximate you guys remember this TV
show called Tanked
but what is a TV show on Bravo or
something called tanked where they give
celebrities like massive fancy fish
tanks that are like tailored to who they
are they gave uh red through one of
those and for an episode they were like
yeah we're gonna make you a a giant fish
tank that has neon fish and has an LED
screen in the back that reacts to music
and it glows and it's got your face on
it there's like this huge elaborate
thing and then when they saw that um it
was going to go on the fourth floor of
his house they were like there's no way
we could do that because we have to
build it in the shop and then bring it
so what they did is uh they decided to
rent a cherry picker that was like a
60-foot like cherry picker to lift it up
like a giant uh elevator outside the
house and they tore out the banister or
the railing for his master bedroom to
push it in through his double door uh
balcony so they did that but once they
got it in there they realized that the
floor that it was gonna go on was too
weak oh my no because it weighs so much
all that water and [__] in it oh my God
so they had to reinforce the ground like
the fourth floor they had to go on the
third floor and build a new
reinforcement underneath so that it
could hold that weight and the tank
itself I think cost like 60 Grand and so
all that extra construction and and the
method they did it they provided all of
that for free
wow and then they found out he's a
renter
[Laughter]
hey why do you got Loop net open on your
computer man
wow it costs them so much money to do
all that but the tank was actually
pretty awesome was it yeah poor fish
that sounds like a hellscape I know it
sounds like a [__] terrorist like the
way the CIA uses deprivation techniques
to like [__] like music and sound
like horses are having seizures no it's
sad too it's sad too because like even
if you're uh so it's a DJ booth you can
go up a Stairway and go on top of the
tank and there's like DJ decks and then
it reacts to the whole like thing but do
fish like Bass
is fast smart it's fast it's sound proof
the whole thing's like soundproof so
even if you're like banging on it it
doesn't like shake the glass or anything
it's super expensive so the fish would
be cool yeah but the thing is you can't
really like uh they they was on contract
that the show would send somebody every
month to like clean the tank for us you
got to clean the water yeah but then
they would also replace the fish because
some of them are just straight up dying
oh my so they would just scoop out all
the fish and put new neon fish all the
time yeah
dude every time you get a new bag of
fish you're like well I don't name them
dude dude and it costs it costs zero
dollars isn't that crazy that show is so
[__] dumb money on [__] fire the
[__] are they still are they still
coming no because uh food didn't want to
who didn't want to keep doing that to
the fish so they they drained it out
took the fish out and they just made it
a terrarium so it's just like plants
yeah yeah and then now it's just
straight up gone you gotta put a python
in there
dude you just took it apart you could
have seen from these terrarium videos
out there oh they're so addicting yeah
guys like put like little bugs in it and
then the bugs like eat the other bugs
and they introduce another species and
they [__] it's a self-contained
ecosystem it's fun as [__] to watch it's
kind of stuff yeah send us a link so no
man's sky but inside us it won't control
your life for a little while I saw one
with a hamster though that was really
interesting hamster I'm interested
little hamster and then the [__]
hamster like comes out eats vegetables
makes a little [__] hot for itself
they introduce a predator to the for
them nah the ones I watched but did you
see I want to see Predators there's one
with the Crawfish that one's pretty cool
is there a predator for the Crawfish nah
yeah
nature is metal I saw one where it's a
it's a crab does a crab have a predator
nah what the [__] Joe it's good he's
watching the kids version I'm watching
the [__] first it's good
have you watched the ant farm one no I
don't even know that but it's like these
nerds they [__] Predator it's right
cat eater
and it's like a whole city and they have
another like that Loop that goes to
another [__] ant farm and then some
of them though there's no Predators but
there's Wars because they big they get
like the ants do you have
War too or you just put [__] liquid
metal in that whole thing bro I watched
I was supposed to say that I love this
[__] dude
they put a liquid aluminum in these like
ant farms and then they make like art
sculptures they blast all the dirt off
of it after they dig it all up and it
incinerates the entire colony in the
dirt because you know they like [__]
do that [__] in the dirt themselves they
pour the metal and incentives the entire
Colony once it dries out they shovel the
entire thing out [__] brush away all
the dirt and now there's a [__] art
installation and then all the ants are
inside of it they're dead it's metal
okay they claim that when they do that
it's colonies that have been abandoned
[__] but they should do it though oh
[__] they're making money off of it get
rid of the colony and this is just an
artistic way of doing it yeah they sell
whoa I think they should do that where
there's invasive ants
when I was killing ants last summer and
it was got personal for me because they
were invading my home all the time I
started I went down a hole with these
videos and I got cathartic I took my
dick on I beat off to this